who does everyone listen to but no one
believes
it's the weather reporter today the
world around you seems pleasant
how would you convey this to an
acquaintance
well you might say the climate is
pleasant today
or maybe the weather is pleasant today
but what's the right terminology here is
it
climate or is it weather
do they both mean the same time to find
out
[Music]
climate and weather both refer to the
local conditions of a place
like temperature humidity rainfall and
so on
but the key factor that differentiates
both of them
is time weather is the atmospheric
condition that we experience
on any particular day for instance
it can be sunny one day and cold on the
other
weather demonstrates the changes of the
atmospheric conditions at a given region
over a very short period of time
let us consider temperature to
understand this better
say your city is moderately hot and its
average temperature
is around 30 degrees celsius but the
temperature will not be 30 every day
there will be frequent variations it
could be 24 at one instant in time
and 26 an hour later so weather refers
to the day-to-day temperatures
the average of these temperatures over
years is referred to as the climate
it explains the weather pattern of a
particular place
over longer periods of time often around
30 years so it means that the climate of
your city
can be moderately hot say around 30
degrees celsius
but at a particular time you can
experience cooler weather as well
so now can you pick the correct
statement between these two
that's correct it is the weather is
pleasant today
now we know what the difference between
climate and weather is
the weather of a particular place keeps
on fluctuating
while the climate is the average of
these fluctuating weather conditions
this tells us that the climate of a
particular place
is fixed now let's consider a situation
here
let us say city x experiences humid
climate
that means on an average the percentage
of water vapor in the air
is high so is it possible that after a
particular time
the climate of city x will change from
humid to dry
that is on an average the percentage of
water vapor becomes low
so the curious question here is can the
climate of a particular place
change drastically over a period of time
if so what are the probable factors
well i leave this q box for you to
explore
let us know about your findings in the
comments section